hallo freuen und herzlich willkommen zu
diesem blog ich wollte mich nur vorher
ganz kurz entschuldigen mehr oder
weniger und zu habe ich in den
kompletten wieder kein einziges mal
geredet ich war in münchen danach in
österreich und auf dem rückweg habe ich
dann bin ich war frankfurt gefahren hab
ich gedacht ich besuche mal hier den
kran kraft da habe ich dann auch bei ihm
gesehen da haben wir auch ein paar geile
videos aufgenommen jetzt will ich
einfach mal sagen viel spaß bei dem wie
blog ich habe kein einziges mal geredet
es sind quasi nur landschaftsbilder mit
musik unterlegt und so weiter vielleicht
gefällt euch trotzdem und viel spaß
[Musik]
ende vom block noch einmal ganz kurz ori
dass ich einfach einmal geredet habe das
werde ich demnächst bei irgendwelchen
anderen blog wenn ich irgendwo sparen
sollte auf jeden fall ändern und dann
hoffe ich einfach ausgefallen wenn es
das getan hat will ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen
morgen kommt auf einem kanal
wahrscheinlich ne coole bertone zusammen
mit max haben uns das gut überlegt wie
wir das zu zweit machen dass auf jeden
fall nicht vergessen mag es in der
beschreibung verlinkt und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal wieder musik ist immer
beschreibung alles weitere chips